MICHALE FEE: So for
the next few lectures,
we're going to be looking at
developing methods of studying
the computational properties
of networks of neurons.
This is the outline for
the next few lectures.
Today we are going to introduce
a method of studying networks
called a rate model where
we basically replace
spike trains with
firing rates in order
to develop simple
mathematical descriptions
of neural networks.
And we're going to start by
introducing that technique
to the problem of studying
feed-forward neural networks.
And we'll introduce the
idea of perceptrons trance
as a method of
developing networks that
can classify their inputs.
Then in the next
lecture, we're going
to turn to largely describing
mathematical tools based
on matrix operations and
the idea of basis sets.
Matrix operations are very
important for studying
neural networks.
But they're also
a fundamental tool
for analyzing data
and doing things
like reducing the dimensionality
of high dimensional data sets,
including methods such as
principal components analysis.
So it's a very
powerful set of methods
that apply both to
studying the brain
and to analyzing the data that
we get when we study the brain.
And then finally we'll turn
to a few lectures that focus
on recurrent neural networks.
These are networks where
the neurons connect
to each other densely
in a recurrent way,
meaning a neuron will
connect to another neuron.
And that neuron will connect
back to the first neuron.
And networks that
have that property
have very interesting
computational abilities.
And we're going to study
that in the context of line
attractors and short-term
memory and hopfield networks.
So for today, the plan is
to develop the rate model.
We're going to show how we
can build receptive fields
with feed forward
networks that we've
described with the rate model.
We're going to take
a little detour
and describe vector notation
and vector algebra, which
is very important for these
models, and also for building
up to the matrix
methods that we'll
talk about in the next lecture.
Again, we'll talk about neural
networks for classification
and introduce the
idea of a perceptron.
So that's for today.
So I've already talked
about most of this.
Why is it that we want
to develop a simplified
mathematical model of neurons
that we can study analytically?
Well, the reason is that we can
really develop our intuition
about how networks work.
And that intuition
applies not just
to the very simplified
mathematical model that we're
developing, but also
applies more broadly
to real networks
with real neurons
that actually generate spikes
and interact with each other
by the more complex
biophysical mechanisms that
are going on in the brain.
So a good example
of this is how we
simplified the detailed
spiking neurons
of the Hodgkin-Huxley
model and approximate that
as an integrate and
fire model, which
captures a lot of the
properties of real neurons.
Simplifies it enough to
develop an intuition,
but captures a lot of
the important properties
of real neural circuits.
All right, so let's
start by developing
the basic idea of a rate model.
Let's start with two neurons.
We have an input neuron
and an output neuron.
The input neuron has some
firing rate given by u.
And the output neuron has
some firing rate given by v.
So we're going to essentially
ignore the times of the spikes
and describe the inputs
and outputs of this network
just with firing rates.
You can think of the rate
as just having units have
spikes per second, for example.
Those neurons, the input
neuron and the output neuron,
are connected to each
other by a synapse.
And we're going to replace
all of the complex structure
of synapses, vesicle release,
neurotransmitter receptors,
long-term depression
and paired spike
facilitation and
depression, all that stuff
we're just going to ignore.
And we're going to replace that
synapse with a synaptic weight
w.
Just to give you the simplest
intuition of how a rate
model works, there are
models where we can just
treat the firing rate
of the output neuron,
for example, as
linear in its input.
And we can simplify
this even to the point
where we can describe the
firing rate of the output neuron
as the synaptic weight w times
the firing rate of the input
neuron.
So that's just to give you a
flavor of where we're heading.
And I'm going to justify
how we can do this
and/or why we can do this.
And then we're going
to build this up
from the case of one input
neuron and one output neuron
to the case where we can
have many input neurons
and many output neurons.
So how do we justify going
from spikes to firing rates?
So remember that the response
of a real output neuron,
a real neuron, to a
single spike at its input,
is some change in the
postsynaptic conductance that
follows an input spike.
And in our model
of a synapse, we
described that the input spike
produces a transient increase
in the synaptic conductance.
And that synaptic
conductance we modeled
as a simple step increase
in the conductance
followed by an exponential
decay as the neurotransmitter
gradually unbinds from the
neurotransmitter receptors.
So we have a transient change
in the synaptic conductance.
That's just a
maximum conductance
times an exponential decay.
Now remember that we wrote
down the postsynaptic--
we can write down the
postsynaptic current that
results from this synaptic input
as the synaptic conductance
times v minus e synapse, the
synaptic reversal potential.
In moving forward
in this model, we're
not going to worry about
synaptic saturation.
So we're just going to imagine
that the synaptic current is
just proportional to the
synaptic conductance.
So now we can write
the conductance
as just some weight times
a kernel that is just
some kernel of unit area.
So what we've done here is we've
just taken the synaptic current
and we've written
it as a constant,
a synaptic weight, times
an exponentially decaying
kernel of area, area 1.
So now if we have a train of
spikes at the input instead
of a single spike,
we can write down
that train of spikes,
the spike train,
as a sum of delta
functions where
the spike times are t sub i.
And if you want to plot
the synaptic current
as a function of
time, you would just
take that spike train
input and do what
with that linear kernel?
We would convolve it, right?
So we would take
that spike train,
convolve it with that
little exponential kernel.
And that would give us
the synaptic current that
results from that spike train.
So let's think for
a moment about what
this quantity is right here.
What is k, this k which
is a little kernel that
has an exponential step, and
then an exponential decay?
What do you get
when you convolve
that kind of smooth kernel
with this spike train here?
What does that look like?
We did that at one point
when we were in class
when we were talking about how
you would estimate something
from a spike train.
What is that?
What is that
quantity right there?
It's sort of a smoothed
version of a spike train,
which is how you would
calculate what, Habiba?
AUDIENCE: Is it a window
for the spike train?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
It's windowed, but what is
it that you are calculating
when you take a spike
train and you convolve it
with some smooth window?
AUDIENCE: Low-pass window?
MICHALE FEE: It's like
a low-pass version
of the spike train.
And remember in the
lecture on firing rates,
we talked about how
that's a good way
to get a time-dependent estimate
of the firing rate of a neuron.
We take the spike train
and just convolve it
with a smooth window.
And if the area of that
smooth window is 1,
then what we're doing
is we're estimating
the firing rate of the
neuron as a function of time.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So k is just a kernel?
MICHALE FEE: k is just is
smooth kernel that happens
to have this exponential shape.
AUDIENCE: Is it like [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Well, that's
our model for how a synapse--
basically, what I'm
saying is that when
you take a spike train and
put it through a synapse, what
comes out the other end
is a smoothed version
of the spike train.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: That's
all this is saying.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE] they have
this area or quantity?
MICHALE FEE: Yep.
If k has-- you remember that
if k has an area 1, then when
you convolve evolve that
kernel with the spike train,
you get a number that has
units of spikes per second.
And that quantity is an
estimate of the local firing
rate of the neuron.
Does that make sense?
So basically, we can
take this spike train,
and by convolve it
with a smooth window,
we can estimate the
number of spikes
per second in that window.
So what do we have here?
We have that the current
is just a constant times
an estimate of the
firing rate at that time.
If k is a kernel, a
smooth kernel with an area
normalized to 1, then
this quantity is just
an estimate of the firing rate.
So let's take a look at that.
So here I have just made
a sample spike train
with a bunch of spikes
that look like they're
increasing in firing rate and
decreasing in firing rate.
If we take that spike train and
convolve it with this kernel,
you can see that you get
this sort of broad bump
that looks like it gets higher
in the middle where the firing
rate is higher.
And it's lower at the edges
where the firing rate is lower.
So the point is that you
can take a spike train
and put it into a neuron.
The response of the neuron
is a smooth low-pass version
of the rate of this
input spike train.
And so you can think about
writing down the input
to this neuron as a weight times
the firing rate of the input.
So that was a way of writing
down the input to this output
neuron from the input
neuron, the current input.
Now what is the firing rate of
the output neuron in response
to that current injection?
So that's what we're
going to ask next.
And you can remember that when
we talked about the integrate
and fire model, we
saw that neurons
in the approximation
of large inputs
have firing rate as
a function of current
that looks like this.
It's zero for inputs below
the threshold current.
For input currents that
aren't large enough
to drive the neuron
to threshold,
the neuron doesn't spike at all.
And then above some
threshold, the neuron
fires approximately linearly
at higher input currents.
So the way that we
think about this
is that the input on is
spiking at some rate.
It goes through a synapse.
That synapse smooths the input
and produces some current
in the postsynaptic
neuron that's
proportional approximately to
the firing rate of the input
neuron.
And the output neuron has
some output firing rate
that's some function
of the input current.
So we can write down the firing
rate of our output neuron,
v. It's just equal to
some function of the input
current, which is just some
function of w times the firing
rate of the input neuron.
And that right there
is the basic equation
of the rate model.
The output firing
rate is some function
of a weight times the firing
rate of the input neuron.
And everything else
about the rate model
is just different rate models
have different numbers of input
neurons where we have more than
one contribution to the input
current.
They can have many
output neurons.
They can have different FI
curves for the output neurons.
Some of them are
non-linear like this.
Some of them are linear.
And we're going to
come back and talk
about the function of
different FI curves
and why different FYI
curves are useful.
Any questions about this?
That's the basic idea.
All right, good.
So let's take one
particularly simple version
of the rate model called
a linear rate model.
And the linear rate model
has a particular FI curve.
That FI curve says that the
firing rate of the neuron
is linear in the input current.
Now why is this a really
weird model of a neuron?
What's fundamentally
non-biological about this?
AUDIENCE: Negative firing rate.
MICHALE FEE: I'm hearing
a bunch of right answers
at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Negative firing rate.
MICHALE FEE: This
neuron is allowed
to fire at a
negative firing rate
if the input
current is negative.
That's a pretty
crazy thing to do.
Why do you think we
would want to do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: Well,
no actually we do.
So you can have
inhibitory inputs
that produce outward currents
that hyperpolarize the neuron.
Any thoughts about that?
It turns out that as soon as
you have your output neurons
have this kind of FI
curve, a linear FI curve,
then the math
becomes super simple.
You can write down very
complex networks of neurons
with a bunch of linear
differential equations.
And it becomes very
easy to write down
what the solution is to
how a network behaves
as a function of its inputs.
And we're going to spend
a lot of time working
with network models that have
linear FI curves because you
can develop a lot of intuition
about how networks behave
by using models like this.
As soon as you have
models like this,
you can't solve the behavior
of the network analytically.
You have to do everything
on the computer.
And it becomes very hard
to derive general solutions
for how things behave.
So we're going to
use this model a lot.
And in this case again, for the
case of this two-neuron network
where we have one output neuron
that receives a synaptic input
from an input neuron, the
firing rate of the output neuron
is just w, the synaptic
weight times the firing rate
of the input neuron.
And we're going to come
back to non-linear neurons
because that
non-linearity actually
does really important things.
And we're going to talk
about what that does.
So now let's look at the
case where our output neuron
has not just one
input but actually
many inputs from a
bunch of input neurons.
So here we have what
we call an input layer,
a layer of neurons
in the input layer.
Each one of those neurons
has a firing rate--
u1, u2, u3, u4, u5.
Each of those neurons sends a
synapse onto our output neuron.
Each one of those synapses
has a synaptic weight.
This weight is w1.
And that's w2, w3, w4, and w5.
Now you can see that the total
input, the total current,
to this output
neuron is just going
to be a sum of the inputs from
each of the input neurons.
The total input is just
a sum of the inputs
from each of the input neuron.
So the synaptic current--
total synaptic current
into this neuron
is w1 times u1, plus w2
times u2, plus w3 times u3,
plus all the rest.
So the response of
our linear neuron,
the firing rate of
is just a sum over
all of those inputs.
So again, in this
case, we're going
to say that the total input
current to this neuron
is the sum over this.
But then because this
is a linear neuron,
the firing rate is just
equal to that current input.
Does that make sense?
So you can see that this
description of the firing
rate of the output
neuron is a sum over all
of those contributions.
It turns out that
this actually can
be written in a much more
compact way in vector notation.
What does that look like?
Does anyone know in vector
notation what that looks like?
AUDIENCE: Dot product.
MICHALE FEE: That's
a dot product.
That's right.
So in general, it's much
easier to write these responses
in vector notation.
And so I'm just
going to walk you
through some basics
of vector notation
for those of you who might
need a few minutes of reminder.
Actually before we get
to the vector notation,
I just want to
describe how we can
use a simple network like this
to build a receptive field.
So you remember that
when we were talking
about receptive
fields of neurons,
we described how
a neuron can have
a maximal response to a
particular pattern of input.
So let's say we
have a neuron that's
sensitive to visual inputs.
And as a function
of one dimension,
let's say along the
retina, this neuron
has a big response if light
comes in central field,
some inhibitory responsive
light comes in outside
of that central lobe.
Well, it turns out
that a very simple way
to build neurons that have
receptive fields like this,
for example, is to have
an input layer that
projects to this neuron that
has this receptive field
and has a pattern
of synaptic inputs
that corresponds to that
pattern in the field.
So you can see that
if this neuron--
so let's say these are
neurons in the retina,
let's say retinal
ganglion cells,
and this neuron is
in the thalamus,
we can build a
thalamic neuron that
has a center-surround
receptive field like this
by having let's
say this neuron has
a strong positive excitatory
synaptic weight onto our output
neuron.
So you can see that
if you have light here
that corresponds to this neuron
having a high firing rate,
that neuron is very effective
at driving the output neuron.
And so the output neuron
has a positive component
of its receptor field
right there in the middle.
Now if this neuron here, which
is in this part of the retina,
if that neuron has a negative
weight onto the output neuron,
then light coming in here
driving this neuron will
inhibit the output neuron.
So if you have a pattern of
weights that looks like this,
0 minus 1, 2 minus 1,
0, that this neuron
will have a receptive
field that looks like that
as a function of its inputs.
So that's a
on-dimensional example.
And you can see
that you write down
the output here
as a weighted sum
of each one of those inputs.
This also works for two
dimensional receptive fields.
For example, if we have
input from the retina that
looks like this where we have--
I guess this was excitatory
here in the center,
inhibitory around, you
can make a neuron that
has a two-dimensional
receptor field like this
by having inputs to
this neuron from all
of those different regions
of the visual field that
have different weights
corresponding to positive
in the center.
So neurons in the
positive synaptic weights
under the output neuron.
And neurons around the edges
have negative synaptic weights.
So we can build any receptive
field we want into a neuron
by just plugging in-- by
putting in the right set
of synaptic weights.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So would you
rule out [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: So in real life,
I assume you mean in the brain?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHALE FEE: So in the
brain, we don't really
know how these
weights are built.
So one idea is that
there are rules that
control the development
of these circuits,
let's say, connections
of bipolar cells
in the retina to
retinal ganglion cells
that control how these
weights are determined
to be positive or negative.
Negative weights are implemented
by bipolar cells connected
to amacrine cells,
which are inhibitory,
and then connect to
the retinal ganglion.
So there's a whole
circuit that gets
built in the retina that
controls whether these weights
are positive or negative.
And those can be programmed by
genetic developmental programs.
They can also be controlled by
experience with visual stimuli.
So there's a lot
we don't understand
about how these
weights are controlled
or set up or programmed.
But the way we think
about how receptive fields
of these neurons emerge is
by controlling the weight
of those synaptic input.
That's the message here--
that receptive fields
emerge from the pattern
of weights from an input
layer onto an output layer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
how many [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: If you're
going to build a model,
let's say, of the retina.
So it just depends on how
realistic you want it to be.
If you wanted to make a model
of a retinal ganglion cell,
you could try to build a
model that has as many bipolar
neurons as are actually
in the receptive field
of that retinal ganglion cell.
Or you could make a
simplified model that
only has 10 or 100 neurons.
Depends on what
you want to study.
All right any other questions?
And again, even for these
more complex models,
you can still write
down a simple rate model
formulation of the firing
rate of the output neuron.
It's just a weighted sum
of the input firing rate.
So each neuron in the input
layer fires at some rate.
It has a weight w.
To get the contribution
of this neuron
to the firing rate
of the output neuron,
you just take that input firing
rate times the synaptic weight,
and add that up then for
all the input layer neurons.
So as I said, we've
been describing
the response of our linear
neuron as this weighted sum.
And that's a little bit
cumbersome to carry around.
So we're going to start using
vector notation and matrix
notation to describe networks.
It's just much more compact.
So we're going to take a little
detour, talk about vectors.
So a vector is just a
collection of numbers.
The number of numbers is
called the dimensionality
of the vector.
If a vector has
only two numbers,
then we can just plot
that vector in a plane.
So for a 2D vector, if that
vector has two components, x1
and x2, then we can
plot that vector
in that space of x1 and
x2, put the origin at zero.
In this case, the vector
has two vector components
or elements, x1 and x2.
And in two dimensions we
describe that as spaces,
as R2, the space of
two real numbers.
We can write down that vector
as a row in row vector notation.
So x is x1, x2.
We can write it as a
column vector, x1, x2,
organized on top of
each other, like this.
Vector sums are very simple.
So if you have two
vectors, x and y,
you can write down the sum
of x and y is x plus y.
That's called the resultant.
X plus y it can be written like
this in column vector notation.
You can see that
the sum of x and y
is just an element by element
sum of the vector elements.
It's called element
by element addition.
Let's look at vector product.
So there are multiple
ways of taking
the product of two vectors.
There's an element by element
product, an inner product,
an outer product that we'll
cover in later lectures.
And also, something
called the cross product
that's very common in physics.
But I have not yet seen the
application of a cross product
to neuroscience.
If anybody can find one of
those, I'll give extra credit.
Element by element product
is called a Hadamard product.
So x times y is just the
element-by-element product
of the elements in
the two vectors.
In Matlab, that
element-by-element product
you compute by x dot star y.
Inner product or dot
product looks like this.
So if we have two
column vectors,
the dot product of
x and y is the sum
of the element-by-element
products.
So x dot y is just x1
times y1 plus x2 times y2,
and so on, plus xn times yn.
And that's that sum that we
saw earlier in our feed forward
network.
OK.
So notice that the dot
product is a scalar.
It's a single number.
It's no longer a vector.
Products have some
nice properties.
They're commutative.
So x.y is equal to y.x.
They're distributive
so that vector w dotted
into the sum of two vectors
is just the sum of the two
separate dot products.
So w dot x plus y
is just w.x, w.y.
And it's also linear.
So if you have a x dot y
that is equal to a times
the quantity x.y.
So if you have vector x and
y dotted into each other,
if you make one of those
vectors twice as long,
then the dot product
is just twice as big.
A little bit more
about inner products.
So we can also write
down the inner product
in matrix notation.
So x.y is a matrix
product of a row vector.
Column vector, you remember
how to multiply two matrices.
You multiply the elements of
each row times the elements
of each column.
So you can see that
this in matrix notation
is just the dot product
of those two vectors.
In matrix notation,
this is a 1 by n matrix.
This is an n by 1.
So 1 row by n columns,
times n rows by 1 column.
And that is equal to a 1 by 1
matrix, which is just a scalar.
All right, in
Matlab, let me just
show you how to write
down these components.
So in this case, x is a column
vector, a 1 by 3 column vector.
y is a 1 by 3 column vector.
You can calculate those
vectors like this.
And z is x transpose times y.
And so that's how
you can write down
the dot product of two vectors.
What is the dot product
of a vector with itself?
It's the square
magnitude of the vector.
So x is just the norm or
And you can see that the
norm of the vector is just--
you can think
about this as being
analogous to the
Pythagorean theorem.
The length of one
side of a triangle
is just the sum of the
squares of all the sides,
the square root of that.
So a unit vector is a
vector that has length 1.
So a unit vector
by definition has
a magnitude of 1,
which means its dot
product with itself is 1.
We can turn any vector
into a unit vector
by just taking that vector,
dividing by its norm.
I'm going to always use this
notation with this little caret
symbol to represent
a unit vector.
So if you see a vector
with that little hat on it,
that means it's a unit vector.
You can express any vector as a
product of a scalar, a length,
times a unit vector
in that direction.
We can find the projection
or component of any vector
in the direction of this
unit vector as follows.
So if we have a
unit vector x, we
can find the projection
of a vector y
onto that unit vector x.
How do we do that?
We just find the normal
projection of that vector.
That distance right there
is called the scalar
projection of y onto x.
If you write down the
length of the vector y,
the norm of the vector y in
the angle between y and x,
then the dot product y.x is
just equal to the magnitude
of y times the cosine of the
angle between the two vectors.
Just simple trigonometry.
We can also define what's called
the vector projection of y
onto x as follows.
So we just draw
that same picture.
So we can find the
projection of y onto x
and add that as a vector.
And that's just this
scalar projection of y
onto x times a unit
vector in the x direction.
So x actually is a unit
vector in this example.
So this vector projection
of y to x is just
defined as y dot x times x.
Any questions about that?
I'm guessing most of you have
seen all of this stuff already.
But we're going to be
using these things a lot.
So I just want to make sure
that we're all on the same page.
And that's just a scalar
times a unit vector.
Let me just give you a
little bit of intuition
about dot products here.
So a dot product is
related to the cosine
of the angle
between two vectors,
as we talked about before.
The dot product
is just magnitude
of x times the magnitude
of y times the cosine
of the angle between them.
So the cosine of the
angle between two vectors
is just the dot product divided
by the product of the magnitude
of each of the two vectors.
So if x and y are unit
vectors, the cosine
of the angle between them
is just the dot product
of the unit vectors.
So again, if x and
y are unit vectors,
then that dot product is
just the cosine of the angle.
Orthogonality.
So two vectors are orthogonal,
are perpendicular, if
and only if their
dot product is 0.
So if we have two
vectors x and y,
they are orthogonal if the angle
between them is 90 degrees.
x.y is just proportional
to the cosine of the angle.
Cosine of 90 degrees is zero.
So if two vectors
are orthogonal,
then their dot
product will be zero.
If their dot product
is zero, then they're
orthogonal with each other.
And using the notation
we just developed,
the vector projection
of y along x
is the zero vector, if those
two vectors are orthogonal.
There is an intuition
that one can
think about in terms of the
relation between dot product
and correlation.
So the dot product is related
to the statistical correlation
between the elements
of those two vectors.
So if you have a
vector x and y, you
can write down the cosine of
the angle between those two
vectors, again, as x.y over
the product of the norms.
And if you write
that out as sums,
you can see that
this is just the sum
of the element-by-element
products--
that's the dot product--
divided by the norm of
x and the norm of y.
And if you have taken
a statistics class,
you will recognize that
as just the Pearson
correlation of a set of numbers
x and a set of numbers y.
The dot product
is closely related
to the correlation between
two sets of numbers.
One other thing that
I want to point out
coming back to the
idea of using this feed
forward network as a
way of receptive field,
you can see that the response
of a neuron in this model
is just the dot product
of the stimulus vector u.
The vector of input firing
rates represents the stimulus,
the dot product of
the stimulus vector u
with the weight vector w.
So the firing rate of the
output neuron is just w.u.
So you can see that
what this means is
that the firing rate
of the output neuron
will be high if there is
a high degree of overlap
between the input, the
pattern of the input,
and the pattern of synaptic
weights from the input layer
to the output neuron.
We can see that w.u is big
when w and u are parallel,
are highly correlated, which
means a neuron fires a lot when
the stimulus matches the pattern
of those synaptic weights.
Now, so you can see
that for a given amount
of power in the stimulus--
so the power is just the
square magnitude of u--
the stimulus that has the best
overlap with the receptive
field, where cosine
of that angle is 1,
produces the largest response.
And so we now have
actually a definition
of the optimal stimulus
of a neuron in terms
of the pattern of
synaptic weights.
In other words, the
optimal stimulus
is one that's essentially
proportional to the weight
matrix.
Any questions so far?
All right, so now let's
turn to the question of how
we use neural networks to do
some interesting computation.
So classification is a
very important computation
that neural networks
do in the brain
and actually in the
application of neural networks
for technology.
So what does
classification mean?
So how does the brain--
how does a neural circuit
decide how a particular input--
let's say that it looks
like you might eat it.
How do we decide--
how do the neural
circuits in our brain
decide whether that
thing that we're seeing
is something edible or
something that will make us sick
based on past experience?
If we see something that
looks like an animal or a dog,
how do we know whether that's a
friendly puppy or a or a wolf?
So these are
classification problems.
And feed forward
circuits actually
can be very good
at classification.
In fact, recent advances
in training neural networks
have actually resulted in feed
forward neural networks that
actually approach human
performance in terms
of their ability to make
decisions like this.
All right.
So basically, a
feed forward circuit
that does
classification like this
typically has an input layer.
It has a bunch of inputs that
represent sensory stimulus.
And a bunch of output
neurons that represent
different categorizations
of that input stimulus.
So you can have a
retinal input here.
Going to other
layers of a network.
And then at the end
of that, you can
have a network that starts
firing when that input was
a dog, or starts firing
another neuron that
starts firing when that input
was a cat, or something else.
Now in general,
classification networks
that have one input layer
and one output layer
can't do this problem.
You can't take a visual
input and have connections
to another layer of
neurons that just light up
when the picture that the
network is seeing is a dog.
Another neuron lights
up when it's a cat.
Generally, there are many
layers of neurons in between.
But today, we're going to
talk about a very simplified
version of the
classification problem
and build up to the sorts of
networks that can actually
do those more complex problems.
So I just want to point out
that the obviously our brains
are very good at
recognizing things.
We do this all the time.
There are hundreds of objects
in every visual scene.
And we're able to recognize
every one of those objects.
But it turns out that there
are individual neurons--
so in this case, I
alluded to the idea
that there are individual
nones in this network that
light up when the
sensory input is a dog
or light up when the
input is an elephant.
And it turns out that that's
actually true in the brain.
So there have
recently been studies
where it's been
possible to record
in parts of the human brain in
patients that are undergoing
brain surgery for the
treatment of epilepsy
or tumors or things like
that where you have to go in
and find parts of the
brain that are defective,
find parts of the
brain that are healthy.
So when you do a
surgery, you can
be very careful to just
do surgery on the damaged
parts of the brain
and not impact parts
of the brain that are healthy.
So there are cases now,
more and more commonly,
where neuroscientists can
work with neurosurgeons
to actually record from
neurons in the brain
in these patients who are
in preparation for surgery.
And so it's been
possible to record
from neurons in the brain.
This was a study from
Itzhak Frieds lab at UCLA.
And this shows recording in
the right anterior hippocampus.
And what this lab did
was to find neurons.
So these were electrodes
implanted in the brain.
And then they basically
take these patients
and they show them thousands
of pictures and look
at how their brains respond
to different visual inputs.
So let me just show you
what you're looking at.
These are just different
pictures of celebrities.
There's Luke Skywalker, Mother
Teresa, and some others.
This paper is getting old
enough that you may not
recognize most of these people.
But if you record from
neurons in the brain,
you can see that--
so what do you see here?
I think that's Oprah.
The image is flashed up on
the screen for about a second.
You record this neuron spiking.
Here you see a couple spikes.
Here's when the image
was actually presented.
And here's where the
image was turned off.
You can see different trials.
So this neuron actually
had a little bit
of a response
right there shortly
after the stimulus
was turned on.
But you can see there's not that
much response in these neurons.
But when they flashed
a different stimulus--
anybody know who that is?
That's Halle Berry.
Look at this neuron.
Every time you
show this picture,
that neuron fires off a
couple spikes very precisely.
If you look at the
histogram, these
are histograms underneath
showing as a function of time
relative to the onset
of the stimulus,
you could see that this
neuron very reliably spikes.
There's a different
picture of Halle Berry.
Neuron spikes.
Different picture,
neuron spikes.
Another picture, neuron spikes.
A line drawing of Halle
Berry, the neuron spikes.
Catwoman, the neuron spikes.
The text, Halle Berry,
the neuron spikes.
It's amazing.
So this group got a
lot of press for this
because they also found
Jennifer Aniston neurons.
They found other celebrities.
This is like some celebrity
part of the brain.
No, it's actually
a part of the brain
where you have neurons that
have very sparse responses
to a wide range of things.
But they're extremely
specific to particular people
or categories or objects.
And it actually is consistent
with this old notion of what's
called the grandmother cell.
So back before people
were able to record
in the human brain like
this, there was speculation
that there might be
neurons in the brain that
are so specific for
particular things,
that there might be one
neuron in your brain
that responds when you
see your grandmother.
And so it turns out
it's actually true.
There are neurons
in your brain that
respond very specifically to
particular concepts or people
or things.
So the question of how
these kinds of neurons
acquire their responses is
really cool and interesting.
So that leads us to the
idea of perceptrons.
Perceptron is the simplest
notion of how you can have
a neuron that responds to a
particular thing that detects
a particular thing and
responds when it sees it
and doesn't respond
when it doesn't.
So let's start with the
simplest notion of a perceptron.
So how do we make a neuron that
fires when it sees something--
let's say a dog--
and doesn't fire
when there is no dog?
So in order to think about
this a little bit more,
so we can begin thinking
about this in the case
where we have a single neuron
input and a single output
neuron.
So if we have a single input
neuron, then what comes in
has to be--
it can't be an image right?
An image is a high
dimensional thing that
has many thousands of pixels.
So you can't write that
down as a simple model
with a single input neuron
and a single output neuron.
So you need to do this
classification problem
in one-dimension.
So we can imagine
that we have an input
neuron that comes from, let's
say, some set of numbers--
I'll make up a story
here-- some set
of neurons that measure
the dogginess of an input.
So let's say that we
have a single input that
fires like crazy when it sees
this cute little guy here.
And fires at a
negative rate when
it sees that thing, which
doesn't look much like a dog.
So we have a single input
that's a measure of dogginess.
And now let's say that we
take this dogginess detector
and we point it
around the world.
And we walk around outside
with our dogginess detector
and we make a bunch
of measurements.
So we're going to see
something that looks like this.
We're going to see a
lot of measurements,
a lot of observations
down here that
are close to zero dogginess.
And we're going to
see a bump of things
up here that correspond to dogs.
Whenever we point our
dogginess detector at a dog,
it's going to give us
a measurement up here.
And we're going to
get a bunch of those.
And those things
correspond to dogs.
So we need to build
a network that
fires when the input is
up here and doesn't fire
when the input is down there.
So how do we do that?
So the central feature
of classification
is this notion of binariness,
of decision-making.
That it fires when you
see a dog and doesn't
fire when you don't see a dog.
So there exists a
classification boundary
in this stimulus space.
You can imagine that there's
some points along this
dimension above which you'll
say that that input is a dog,
below which you
say that it isn't.
And we can imagine that
that classification boundary
is right here.
It's a particular number.
It's a particular value
of our dogginess detector,
above which we're
going to call it a dog,
and below which we're going
to call it something else.
How do we make this
neuron respond by firing
when there's a dog and not
firing when there's no dog?
Can we use a linear neuron?
Can we use one of
our linear neurons
that we just talked
about before?
We can't do that because a
linear neuron will always fire
more the bigger the input is.
And it will fire less
if the dogginess is 0.
And it will even
fire more negatively
if the dogginess
input is negative.
So a linear neuron is
terrible for actually
making any decisions.
Linear neurons always go,
ah, well, maybe that's a dog.
Not really.
There's no decisions.
So in order to
have a decision, we
need to have a particular
kind of neuron.
And that kind of neuron
uses something very natural.
In biophysics, it's the
spike threshold of neurons.
Neurons only fire when the
input is above some threshold,
generally.
There are neurons that
are tonically active.
But let's not worry about those.
So many neurons only
fire when the input
is above some threshold.
So for decision-making
and classification,
a commonly used kind of neuron
takes this idea to an extreme.
So for perceptrons, we're
going to use a simplified
model of a neuron
that's particularly
good at making decisions.
There's no if, ands,
or buts about it.
It's either off or on.
It's called a binary unit.
And a binary unit uses
what's called a step
function for its FI curve.
That step function is 0--
the output is 0 if the
input is zero or below.
And the output is 1 if
the input is above 0.
We can use that step
function to create
a neuron that responds
when the input is
above any threshold we want.
So we can write down the output
firing rate is this function,
a step function-- that
function of a quantity that's
given by w times u, the synaptic
weight times the input firing
rate, minus that threshold.
So you can see if
w times u, which
is the input synaptic current,
if that synaptic current is
above theta, then this
argument to this function
is greater than 0,
then the neuron spikes.
If this argument is negative,
then the neuron doesn't spike.
So by changing theta, we can put
that decision boundary anywhere
we want.
Does that make sense?
Usually the way we do
this is we pick a theta.
We say our neuron
has a theta of 1.
And then we do everything else--
we do everything else
we're going to do
with this network with a theta.
So what I'm going to talk
about today are just two cases.
Where theta is a fixed
number that's non-zero,
or theta that's a fixed
number that is equal to 0.
So we're going to talk
about those two cases.
So the neuron fires
when the input w
u is greater than theta.
And it doesn't fire
when it's less.
So now the output neuron fires
whenever the input neuron
has a firing rate greater
than this decision boundary.
So the decision boundary,
the u threshold,
is equal to theta divided by w.
Does that make sense?
U threshold is the
neuron fires when
u is greater than
theta divided by w.
So the way we learn, the
way this network learns
to fire when that u is above
this classification boundary
is simply by
changing the weight.
Does that make sense?
So we're going to
learn the weight such
that this network fires whenever
the input says there's a dog.
And it doesn't fire whenever
the input says there's no dog.
So let's see what happens
when w is really small.
If w is really small,
then what happens
is all of these-- remember,
this is the input.
That's that the
dogginess detector.
If w is really small,
then all these inputs
get collapsed to a small input
current into our output neuron.
Does that make sense?
So all those different
inputs, dogs and non-dogs,
gets multiplied
by a small number.
And all those inputs
are close to 0.
And if all those
inputs are close to 0,
they're all below the threshold
for making this neuron spike.
So this network is not
good for detecting dogs
because it says it never
fires, whether the input
is a dog or a non-dog.
Now what happens
if w is too big?
If w is really big, then this
range of dogginess values
gets multiplied by a big number.
And you can see that a bunch of
non-dogs make the neuron fire.
Does that make sense?
So now this one fires
for dogs plus doggie-ish
looking things,
which, I don't know,
maybe it'll fire
when it sees a cat.
That's terrible.
So you have to choose w to make
this classification network
function properly.
Does that make sense?
And if you choose
w just right, then
that classification
boundary lands
right on the threshold
of the neuron.
And now the neuron spikes
whenever there is a dog.
And it doesn't spike
whenever there's not a dog.
So what's the message here?
The message is we can
have a neuron that
has this binary threshold.
And what we can do is simply
by changing the weight,
we can make that
threshold land anywhere
on this space of inputs.
And we can actually use the
error to set the weight.
So let's say that
we made errors here.
We classify dogs as non-dogs
because the neuron didn't fire.
You can see that this was the
case when w was too small.
So if you classify
dogs as non-dogs,
then you need to make w bigger.
And if you classify
non-dogs as dogs,
you need to make w smaller.
And by measuring what
kind of errors you make,
you can actually fix the weights
to get to the right answer.
So this is a method
called supervised
learning where you
set w randomly.
You take a guess.
And then you look at
the mistakes you make.
And you use those
mistakes to fix the w.
In other words, you
just look at the world
and you say, oh, that's a dog.
And then your mom
says, no, that's not
a dog, that's something else.
And you adjust your weights.
I think that was the
example I just gave.
You're going to
make that w smaller.
In another case, you'll make
the other kind of mistake
and you'll fix the weights.
So this is called a perceptron.
And the way you learn the
weights in a perceptron is you
just classify things and you
figure out what kind of mistake
you made and you use that
to adjust the weights.
So that's the basic idea of
a perceptron and perceptron
learning.
And there's a lot of
mathematical formalism
that goes into how
that learning happens.
And we're going to
get to that in more
detail in the next lecture.
But before we do that,
I want to go from having
a one-dimensional case.
So here we had a one-dimensional
network that was just
operating on dogginess.
And then we have a
single neuron that
says, was that a dog or not.
But in general, you're
not classifying things
based on one input.
Like for example when you
have to identify a dog,
you have a whole
image of something.
And you have to classify
that based on an image.
So let's go from the
one-dimensional case
to a two-dimensional case.
So the classification isn't
done on one-dimension,
but it's based on many
different features.
So let's say that we have
two features, furriness
and bad breath.
That dog doesn't really
look like it has bad breath.
but mine does.
So you can have two
different features, furriness
and bad breath.
And dogs are generally,
let's say, up here.
Now you can have other animals.
This guy is
definitely not furry.
So he's down here somewhere.
And you can have
this guy up here.
He's definitely furry.
So you have these two
dimensions and a bunch
of observations in
those two dimensions,
in those higher dimensions.
And you can see
that, in this case,
you can't actually apply that
one-dimensional decision-making
circuit to discriminate dogs
from these other animals.
Why is that?
Because if I apply my
one-dimensional perceptron
to this problem,
you can see that I
could put a boundary
here and it will
misclassify some of these
non-furry animals as dogs.
Or I could put my
classifier here
and it will misclassify
some of these cats as dogs.
So how would I separate dogs
from these other animals
if I had this
two-dimensional space?
What would I do?
How would I put a
classification bound?
If this doesn't work and this
doesn't work, what would I do?
You could put a
boundary right there.
So in this little
toy problem, that
would perfectly separate
dogs from all these non-dogs.
So how do we do that?
Well, what we want is some
way of projecting these inputs
onto some other
direction so that we
can put a classification
boundary right there.
And it turns out there's a very
simple network that does that.
It looks like this.
We take each one of those
detectors, a furriness detector
and a bad breath detector,
and we have those two inputs.
We have those inputs synapse
onto our output neuron
with some weight w1
and some weight w2,
and we calculate the
firing rate of this neuron.
Now we have this problem of
how do we place this decision
boundary correctly.
What's the answer?
Well, in the
one-dimensional example,
what is it that we learned?
What was it that we
were actually changing?
We were taking guesses.
And if we were right
or wrong, we did what?
We changed the weight.
And that's exactly
what we do here.
We're going to learn to
change these weights to put
that boundary in
the right place.
If we just take a random
guess for these weights,
that line is just going to
be some random position.
But we can learn to
place that line exactly
in the right place to
separate dogs from non-dogs.
So let's just think
a little bit more
about how that
decision boundary looks
as a function of the weight.
So let's look at this case
where we have two inputs.
So now you can see that the
input to this neuron is w.u.
So now if we use our binary
neuron with a threshold,
we can see that the firing
rate of this output neuron
is this step function
operating on or acting
on this input, w.u minus theta.
So now what does that look like?
The decision
boundary happens when
this quantity is pulled to 0.
When this input is greater
than 0, the neuron fires.
When this input is less
than 0, it doesn't fire.
So what does that look like?
So you can see the
decision boundary is
when w.u minus theta equals 0.
Does anyone know what that is?
Remember, u is our input space.
That's what we're asking,
where is this decision
boundary in the input space.
w is some weights that
are fixed right now,
but we're gradually going
to change them later.
So what is that an equation for?
It's a line.
That's an equation for a line.
If u is our input, you
can see w.u equals theta.
That's an equation
for a line, base of u.
The slope and
position of that line
are controlled by the weights
w and the threshold theta.
So you can see this is w1,
u1, plus w2, u2 equals theta.
In the space of u1 and
u2, that's just a line.
So let's look at the case
where theta equals 0.
You can see that if you have
this input space, u1 and u2,
if you take a particular
input u and dot it into w--
so let's just pick a w in
some random direction--
the neuron fires when the
projection of u along w
is positive.
So you can see here, the
projection of u along w
is positive.
So in this case for this
u the neuron will fire.
So any u that has a
positive projection along w
will make the neuron spike.
So you can see that
all of these inputs
will make the neuron spike.
All of these inputs will
make the neuron not spike.
Does that make sense?
So you can see that the
decision boundary, this boundary
between the inputs
that make the neuron
spike and the inputs that
don't make the neuron spike,
is a line that's
orthogonal to w.
Does that make sense?
Because you can see
that any u, any input,
along this line will
have zero projection,
will be orthogonal to w.
Will have zero projection.
And that's going to correspond
to that decision boundary.
So let's just look
at a couple of cases.
So here a set of points that
correspond to our non-dogs.
Here are a set of points
that correspond to our dog.
You can see that if you have
a w in this direction, that
produces a decision boundary
that nicely separates
the dogs from the non-dogs.
So what is that w?
that w is 1, comma, 0.
And we're going to consider
the case where theta is 0.
Let's look at this case here.
So you can see that
here are all the dogs.
Here are all the non-dogs.
You can see that if you drew
a line in this direction,
that would be a good
decision boundary
for that classification problem.
You can see that
a w corresponding
to solving that problem
is 1, comma, minus 1,
and theta equals 0.
Let's look at the case
where theta is not 0.
So here we have w.u minus theta.
When theta is not 0, then
the decision boundary is w.u
equals some non-zero theta.
That's also a line.
It's a equation for a line.
When theta is 0, that
decision boundary
goes through the origin.
When theta is not 0,
the decision boundary
is offset from the origin.
So we could see that
when we had theta is 0,
the decision boundary--
that network only
works if the decision boundary
is going through the origin.
In general, though, we can put
the decision boundary anywhere
we want by having
this non-zero theta.
So here's an example.
Here are a set of points
that are the dogs.
that are the non-dogs.
If we wanted to
design a network that
separates the dogs
from the non-dogs,
we could just draw a line
that cleanly separates
the green from the red dots.
And now we can calculate
w that gives us
that decision boundary.
How do we do that?
So the decision boundary
is w minus u.theta.
Let's say that we
want to calculate
this weight vector w1 and w2.
And let's just say that our
neuron has a threshold of 1.
So we can see that we have
two points on the decision
boundary.
We have one point here,
a, comma, 0, right there.
We have another point
here, 0, comma, b.
And we can calculate
the decision boundary
using ua.w equals theta,
ub.w equals theta.
That's two equations and
two unknowns, w1 and w2.
So if I gave you a set of points
and I said calculate a weight
for this perceptron that will
separate one set of points
from another set of
points, and I give you
a theta for the output
neuron, all you have to do
is draw a line that
separates them,
and then solve those
two equations to get
w1 and w2 for that network.
It's very easy to do
this in two dimensions.
You can just draw a
line and calculate
the w that corresponds to
that decision boundary.
Any questions about that?
Just that, if you
have questions,
you should ask because
that's going to be
a question you ought to solve.
So you can see in two dimensions
you can just look at the data,
decide where's the decision
boundary, draw a line,
and calculate the weights w.
But in higher dimensions,
it's a really hard problem.
In high dimensions,
first of all,
remember in high dimensions
you've got images.
Each pixel in that image
is a different dimension
in the classification problem.
So how do you write
down a set of weights?
So imagine that's an
image, that's an image.
And you want to find
a set of weights
so that this neuron fires
when you have the dog,
but doesn't fire when
you have the cat.
That's a really hard problem.
You can't look at
those things and decide
what that w should be.
So there's a way of taking
inputs and taking the answer,
like a 1 for a dog
and a 0 for non-dogs,
and actually finding a set
of weights that will properly
classify those inputs.
And that's called the
perceptron learning rule.
And we're going to talk about
that in the next lecture.
So that's what we did today.
And we're going to
continue working
on developing methods
for understanding
neural networks next time.